عشره طائره ميغا 29 تعهدت سلوفاكيا
بارسالها الى اوكرانيا الشهر الماضي وحجزت
حينها مقعد المتبرع الاوروبي الثاني
بمقاتله بعد هولندا غير ان سلوفاكيا في
موقف محرج حاليا لا تحسد عليه فطائراتها
تعيبها اعطال تسبب بها تسبب بها فنيون روس
كيف ذلك وزير الدفاع سلوفاكي اعلن ان
الطائرات المقاتله التي تم تسليمها
لاوكرانيا معيبا قادره على الطيران لكنها
عاجزه عن تنفيذ مهام قتاليه وفقا للتعبيره
الاجزاء المعطله الوحيده في الطائره
الحربيه جميعها او جمعها تقنيون روس عملوا
في قاعده القوات الجويه السلوفاكيا حتى
العام الماضي وفق ذلك
بموجب اتفاق طويل الامد مع روسيا تمركز
الفنيون الروس في سلوفاكيا لامتلاكهم
معرفه اكبر بالطائرات السوفيتيه مقاتلات
ميجا 29 وهي طائره اسرع من الصوت وهي من
الجيل الرابع قدرتها مذهله على المناوره
والوصول للاهداف واطلاق الصواريخ من
مسافات بعيده كفاءه هذه الطائره بالمعارك
يعتمد على عده عوامل اولها العدد لما في
ذلك من اثر وفعاليه اما العمل الاخر
فيعتمد على خبرته اوكرانيا في استخدامها
وتوفير قطع غيار يمكن استخدامها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات